[Music]
right
welcome to canor just take that
beautiful view in
for a moment we are in the middle of
kerala right on that incredible ocean
and um i'm about to cut one of my
favorite cuisines at indian i fell in
love with india
literally as a boy growing up because uh
our landlord was
indian and he used to teach my mum how
to make the most amazing curries i can't
think of a much better way to celebrate
his landscape by making an amazing curry
but this time i'm going to do with a
beautiful acorn squash
curry okay now they call these red
pumpkins here
but it's a beautiful hard shell acorn
look at the color of that inside
um from there whether you're grilling
some shrimp
uh the most amazing fish it goes
beautifully with fish and we'll show you
the basics and i want you to take it
to the next level now i'm gonna start
the actual gravy
ie the curry in a minute quick look at
the ingredients down here
okay all sourced locally onions garlic
lime leaves caffeine lime leaves
turmeric coriander here
really powerful red chili super dark one
it's super hot a little bit of palm
sugar
and freshly grated coconut there okay
now the secret for me first off
is to get this beautiful pumpkin i'm
gonna grill it
and sit up almost like uh music i am so
hot honestly it's 38 degrees here and it
is so hot
um grill it and get a nice char
okay so i'm gonna take wedgies out and
i'll show you why because i'm going to
grill this
and then grate some of the pumpkin to go
inside that curry
now top and tail say those little bits
to grate
so there's no waste and then from there
see those little lines there the curves
that's the easiest part for you to slice
down
through and through again okay
holding the knife nice and firm and just
go through
now at the bottom just take
a little slice off just so it can sit up
upright
nice just like that so i can sit upright
and the idea
is you pick up one of these beautiful
little sort of boats
chew away i'm gonna cover that in that
wonderful pumpkin
curry now next off get these
in a bowl lightly season them okay
a touch of salt a touch of pepper i'm
gonna mix this with a little touch of
ghee
okay you know salt pepper
roll these around now the idea here now
is to get
these beautifully grilled okay now if
you grill the pumpkin
let it sit for a while it actually sort
of steams it inside so it's going to be
a really fierce
super fast grill but look
i want to lightly season
pumpkin with the red chili
powder a little touch
of ground coriander
and a little touch of that beautiful
fresh turmeric okay
now roll that around okay
spiced up
so look lift that up
and then from there just very carefully
start grilling these okay
now you can do these in the pan
roast them in the oven we'll do them
outside so make sure you get lots of
colour on there
before you turn it over
[Music]
lift them up a little bit so they cook a
bit slower that's where the flavor is
first off
slicing onions the base of any good
indian gravy is always in the onions
okay and the secret here
is not cutting them too thin
so they don't burn okay so
beautifully done
in with a touch of ghee okay
nice and hot start sweating off those
onions
really important sweat them
give that a nice little mix
a touch of salt a little bit of pepper
chop the garlic
powder goes
[Music]
again nothing fancy about this kai
okay ginger
chopped
i think that's the beauty about this
style
of cuisine there's nothing fancy
it's packed with flavor and
it's so simple to do ginger in
fresh green chillies on the seeds in
it's a nice
sweet acorn squash pumpkin so i can take
the heat of the chili's
green chillies in
big lime leaves beautiful so fragrant
and then from there i'll use one two
three dried red chilies okay now
remember that number
why you have to look for them after pull
those out
and rest
sit down
now into the heat okay tablespoon of
turmeric beautifully done that'll give
it a nice
wonderful color and get them toasted
a touch of coriander in
that i'm gonna go for some beautiful
powerful red chili
teaspoon and then not so red
again powerful but delicious
cook that out now really important to
toast all those spices
[Music]
and now for the pumpkin
take two nice wedges
in half and half
again into the corners that take you
greater
okay get your
big side there and literally just great
look
yes
again
top that up with the touch of water
beautiful now once you've got the color
on those
you can fold and literally
just cover and that will help to steam
them
but more importantly
allow the cooking process so what we do
is take it off put it on there
wrap them in
color is the important part that's gonna
be the flavor
and then from there literally back on
and let them cook nice and slowly
bring that up to the boil let cook out
now
now finish that with a little bit of
palm sugar okay that's going to give a
little bit more sweetness which goes
really well
with the heat here okay palm sugar in
and then look fresh lime juice okay
squeeze that in there
get rid of the pips and that's going to
literally lift all that wonderful
coconut flavor and lime
with that beautiful pumpkin is delicious
now i've got this coconut meal
it's going to give that right the last
minute just a touch
of body to that pumpkin leave a little
bit
on top mix that in with a beautiful
texture
now you can see now remember i said to
you
three chiles dried chilis okay
depending on who your guests are you
decide whether leave them or not
so i like to take chili's out
one two
three turn them out look at the texture
there
beautiful now for the most exciting part
the serving of it
get your beautiful
acorn squash
beautiful
look the fork so they should just go
through
and they just go through so softly
useful
now from there lift them up
and sit them on your plate
start spooning that spoon by spoon
over the pumpkins
be generous with this part be generous
with that curry
don't forget the pumpkin is part of the
gravy
and then finally fresh
grated coconut there we go
a beautiful roasted acorn squash
spiced pumpkin curry i can't think of a
better place
to make something so beautiful right in
front of the beach
here in kerala let me know in the
comments what you think of that amazing
dish and if you missed uncharted
trust me you can watch it on the link
below or on the nat geo app